time now for another invigorating edition of
CBS morning's deals where we share items that
might help make your day a little bit brighter a
little bit better all at exclusive discounts to
start shopping now scan the QR code on your screen
there it is upper left or visit cbsdeals.com Candy
Carter Chief content officer of the e-commerce
company knocking joins us now candy okay we gotta
go we gotta go I'm gonna make you a hero in your
house okay we are talking about mops it's called
the wow wow what it's called come on over here
Tony look at that you pull this back the lights
come on you hit the button look at that it does
the mopping for you here spray look at that bam
[Music]
you can take the pads off you can wash them use
it over and over again amazing they also had an
announcement candy though wow wow that's a wow let
me tell you no more lugging buckets dirty water
all day long okay set it up what's the what's the
brand name look at that Nelly oh Nelly wow okay
every time you say it all right he here this
is a spray that helps with deodorizing odors
your kids your kids all their sports equipment
you can make it table salt water Shake It Up
Put it on here 16 minutes electrolyze water okay
natural here we go right here 100 to 199 47 off
all day long I love it Game Changer all right
these are Tiki tones this is one of our best
selling products this is the pros of speakers
yes but check this out upgraded high quality
speaker okay handle you can drop in your bag go
to the beach the light is beautiful you don't
have kids knocking over your real tiki torches
here's the big thing a hundred of them you can
sink a hundred of these oh wow hello Father's
Day graduation parties get at least four or
five of these they're 44.99 they're usually
80 because it's a really good speaker it has
surround sound Imagine music you could play Candy
uh oh wait a minute I have to play the music 44.99
we got it okay that is my move we love it 44 off
okay Gail this is you all day long seriously okay
so this is the thing you have you're going to
a concert going to a concert a party whatever
you have your crossbody but your phone doesn't
fit right all fits in here put the phone in you
put your license here you put your cards in here
goes across about it so I'm taking my kids to a
concert Bryson tiller yeah we're gonna have this
look throw your hands in the air like okay this
is you at Bruno Mars all day you can take your
selfies take your pictures use your Apple pay
talk on the phone and shout out to the airport
airport traveling internationally you can't
get pickpocketed like that 19.99 under 20 bucks
amazing get a bunch of these you like the which
color the pink the pink one yes love it that
might find its way into my purse all day I'm
excited about this because this may surprise
you but my feet are not my best feature okay
I got everything it's not pretty guess what me
too we don't bounce out of bed anymore right
you're like so look all right well think less of
me but my feet are not my best okay go ahead rub
it rub your feet like this loosen up those
muscles soak in warm water put the charcoal
scrub on scrub that toe jam oh you have anything
for callus remover well apparently this is super
helpful we have 30 seconds we have to hurry all
right then you rub this off put this delicious
smelling smell that can you even put that on your
your feet feel like butter best part you put your
toe separator on it stretches the foot so it
is listen why do I want to stretch this because
because you're always wearing those heels okay
roll out those muscles do and then stretch your
foot forty dollars 31 off normally 60 bucks right
that's what a pedicure costs but you can do this
over and over so I should just take all of these
things yes and listen you need your you need your
feet cute for the summer okay Carter thank you
very much of course we do partner with all these
companies to get the deals you just heard about
to buy anything I do like flip-flops scan the QR
code on your screen or head to cbsdeals.com
to start shopping now you know you want to